it's day five of the Kanye pocalypse and
just as predicted if you step out of the
box the other is still in jail we'll
turn on you
so now Donald Trump has two black
friends I hope ben Carson doesn't get
jealous like I don't even know what
happened here
I think Kanye West just realized he's
too rich to not be Republican I don't
even know what it is we have the right
to independent thoughts and I
independently think that Kanye has lost
his mind what an overreaction you think
the guy advocated for child marriage but
it's just like high school isn't it the
person who won't act like everyone else
gets the shaft isn't it odd that
Hollywood lectures us on bullying and
diversity but when it comes right down
to it they're groupthink enforcers
intolerant of individuality so why is
that
it's the curse again of identity
politics which puts the group before the
person also behind the mockery is it
fear that their target might be on to
something and the markers are being left
behind when someone dares to be
different in a way that comes with a
cost
you either reevaluate your own choices
or seek to silence him or her which
leads me to another criticism that those
on the right lauding Kanye would rip him
apart if his comments were left-wing
what if it was about needing more gun
control it's actually a fair point
except it misses the big picture what
Kanye is doing unlike that position
isn't a reflection of the same
conventional assumptions that gets great
press no this is a daring move because
it goes against that very tide thus it's
one that costs you capital support from
your entertainment pals and even record
sales he didn't join a parade he left a
prison and he's paying for it but maybe
that's why Kanye did it he realized that
he could absorb the slings and arrows
that others couldn't who does that
remind you of
and not Donald Trump me yes you it
rhymes with Jesus okay anyway you wanna
hear what Donald Trump had to say it's
pretty prettier yeah
you're comparing yeah I'm saying yeah he
took these suffered the slings it he is
risking himself for the good of others
yeah all the way I find it I mean people
talk about looking for people who are
Christ like the guys willing to
sacrifice a lot of himself for others
laughter because I'm also sacrificing
myself well I don't did that for you on
okay let's go to this Donald Trump
talking about Kanye I get along with
Kyle I get along with a lot of people
frankly but Kanye
looks and he sees black unemployment at
the lowest it's been in the history of
our country
okay he sees that stuff and he's smart
and he says you know what Trump is doing
a much better job than the Democrats did
when I see a Kanye sticking to his guns
or when I see others and there are
plenty of others sticking to their guns
and coming out and saying it Dana
well you know one of the things that
I've learned today is that it's your
point about you getting kicked out of
your tribe mm-hmm is that do you know
that he was actually they said that
Kanye was part of the alt-right yeah I
know he's part of it all right and you
know how I feel about him in terms of
the past night but I can I'm willing to
let it go conservatives have been saying
similar things for many many years
sometimes in terms of politics and
public policy timing is everything this
is an opening and if President Trump can
take it go for it that's that's the
thing it feels like up a possibility for
something I mean I hate to take issue
with the president the United States I
doubt Kanye is looking at black
unemployment and say you know what it's
tax cut policy
I just think Kanye likes controversy
yeah and Kanye likes to like move
outside of the box and it works use an
independent
thinker he's not afraid to take the
slings and arrows is this not about
politics Kanye's admitting he's not a
Republican he's not a Democrat I think
he honestly just likes trunk
what's wrong with I think he respects
Trump and he likes him and he's not
afraid to get out of that Lane and say
he likes the guy and he's not gonna
listen to the mob set you have to hate
this guy he respects individuality and
when an individual gets out of line
the mob comes down and slams you he's
been called mentally ill he's been
called a sellout he's been called
everything they were mocking him on
late-night he doesn't care though and I
think that's what makes Kanye different
and makes him have that dragon energy
could I just throw that this is a tweet
from chance of rapper black people don't
have to be Democrats all right that
doesn't necessarily mean they have to be
Republicans wand but is it could you
interpret that tweet as saying that he
wants the Democrats to improve their
party do not take us for granted fedora
so don't ignore us as Republicans do
don't take for granted as the old saying
but in the case of Kanye West this guy I
mean you know he he said that while
Obama called him a jerk for his being
rude to Taylor Swift and like yeah when
he was in the hospital when he was
addicted to opium who invited him it was
Ronald Troy so that's the basis there's
no policies no substance so when you
talk about getting out of the box wrong
with that what there was a little sub
since he said what is Obama done for
Chicago when it comes to substance this
guy has nothing this is the guy in fact
who said Cosby was innocent this is the
guy who condemned george w bush you guys
are suddenly flocking to him because
it's convenient but why you would take
him seriously i have no i wouldn't you
take him seriously provocateur that's
your that's your opinion but he's
actually a serious businessman is hugely
successful no you don't know because I
don't think you're very familiar with
his background I don't quite and he's
entitled to have his opinion like is
building to diminish him because what
he's a the guy was in the hospital he's
the basis is why do you ask them to come
so
faces to totally disregard and just
debase an individual to say that they
had mental illness problems that they
shouldn't they should be discounted in
their opinion I just think that is a
very myopic short-sighted viewpoint and
it's not very fair he's somebody that
you should say listen go ahead and say
what you want to say give your opinion
he was invited over to Trump Tower it
was at the transition and they had a
meeting maybe they did talk about
business maybe they did talk about a way
to talk to you know no you're not a
modern unity world this is a matter and
it seems to me to be so trivial but
again we gotta move on